protests against a coal mine in a
condemned German villager expected to
Peak this weekend Riot police have moved
into lutzarat to remove protesters
trying to prevent The Village's
demolition to allow the mine to be
expanded Greta tunberg is expected to
join the demonstrations along with other
youth climate activists earlier we spoke
to one of the protesters leading the
movement Louisa neubauer the coal under
the village is not needed to secure
Germany's energy Supply so what is being
made up here is this crisis narrative
where the government comes up to tackle
the prices with the coal effectively
just creates way more crises than we can
ever tackle
uh Europe correspondent Adam Parsons is
in lutzerat and sent us this update a
short while ago well there really isn't
much left of lutherat anymore it's
caught between two enormous developments
one is the gatoid coal mine which creeps
ever nearer and the second thing is all
around us the destruction of this small
village uh you can hear Diggers at the
moment pulling apart buildings and the
third thing that is happening here is of
course a huge police presence as the
police try to get rid of protesters who
have built barricades or put themselves
up trees in order to try to stop uh rwe
this giant Energy company seizing
control of this land and of course
Lutheran has become a focal point of
global interest in the questions around
climate change in energy policy and also
in that any question of why Germany one
of the richest countries in the world
has decided to continue expanding an
enormous coal mine and not just any old
call this is lignite the one of the
dirtiest fossil fuels imaginable now the
flip side of that is rwe says that
literate has to go but that five other
villagers are going to be saved also a
lot of people pointing out that this is
a result of Germany deciding to close
down nuclear power stations a few years
ago and now like so many other countries
finding itself squeezed in its energy
Supply and turning once again to Coal
those are other theoretical questions
but this is what's happening on the
ground destruction of a village the
wiping out of a place where people and
families used to live that is why
thousands are gathering here today to
protest against this the reality is
though it's very hard to imagine that
Lutheran will still be standing in a
matter of weeks time